Welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
It's several questions submitted.
If you're new to this,
you can submit your questions on the member site
and any of the pages of the member site.
I believe the box is a blue box at the bottom.
You can submit your blue here.
Zoom call questions.
Or you can just chat them in as we go.
So feel free to chat in a question in everyone.
And we'll get started with the ones that were submitted.
Remember also to look at the announcements on the home page of the member site.
There were no new announcements for today.
Okay, here's a question because we've had this come up.
How long did the hammer bulbs last for the right machine?
What's the hammer bulb?
Well, so the hammer bulbs are the long tubular bulbs.
They were called hammer bulbs because you could hit them with a hammer
and they would break.
Well, that's the plexiglass outside you could hit with a hammer.
Maybe they had a different name for a hammer bulb.
Maybe it was invented by Mr. Hammer.
I don't know.
But I always said they're fairly unbreakable.
If you hit the plexiglass,
the plexiglass you could crack.
Of course, if you hit it hard,
but you the glass inside is encased in the plexiglass.
And the glass inside is the bulb.
And inside the bulb is a gas.
And the gas is what lights up when certain frequencies are transmitted through that gas.
And that is what is treating you as the frequencies through that light.
So can you break them?
Well, if you hit it hard enough with the hammer,
you probably break the plexiglass and you could break the glass.
I haven't had anybody yet.
In all the years doing this, break the glass.
But I have had it happens all the time,
where the wires burn out,
or the wires get pulled out,
or somebody trips on the wires,
and it gets damaged at where it plugs into the right machine.
Or you drop the bulb,
and it hits right at the wrong way,
and it damages the connection of where the wire is connected to the bulb.
If you damage the connection where the wire is connected to the glass bulb inside itself,
most times you can't see the damage unless you took it all apart.
You can't see the damage.
And the gas will leak out.
So if you damage the wire as it's soldered to the glass itself,
it's welded, I think, with a glass weld.
So you can't repair that.
And if it was damaged, the gas would leak out.
And unless you are a bulb manufacturer that is using the specific gases that are in the bulb,
you can't fix it.
It's not repairable.
So if that's the case,
I mean, the bulb manufacturer will repair it either.
It's just a possible item.
So unfortunately, that isn't fixable.
We've had several, that has happened dozens and dozens of times,
where people drop it,
or drops out of bed, and it falls just wrong,
and it just breaks that and the gas leaks out.
And it looks perfectly normal.
You can't even see sometimes if you take it apart,
but it's just not working.
Other ways that the bulbs burn out is the wires.
That's the most common way that they burn out,
because you are running high frequencies through this,
and it can just literally fry the wires.
And those can be soldered together.
I can't, I don't do that,
and the manufacturer does not do that.
Understand the price of the bulbs.
We don't make a penny off the bulbs.
So we can't guarantee the bulbs.
So if you get them at their working,
and then something happens, they stop working.
There's no, we don't have any guarantee of the bulbs.
So we just can't, we don't get anybody back,
and we're a small clinic.
We can't, we just can't do it.
So be careful with it.
No, just in the last year or so, and closed.
So most of these people that are on this call right now
wouldn't have seen this in the last year.
So we even closed a sheet of paper with the rights
that says this is delicate equipment.
And, you know, most of the time,
let's be honest, I was the first clinician ever
to start setting people home with rife machines.
These are initially used to use in clinics.
So you have to treat them like a delicate piece of equipment.
You have to be really careful with them.
And I know most people are, but, you know,
if you have kids and dogs and, you know, animals and grandkids
and things can get jostled and things can break.
So you don't have to be careful with them.
So yes, the bulbs can break. How long do they last?
Depends on how a care that goes in,
even if it took really good care.
If you're already high frequencies with cancer frequencies
through these bulbs, you can burn out the wire.
And it's no fault of yours.
It just is what it is.
So they can, you know, they can burn out in six months.
They can burn out in three months.
They can burn out in, you know,
I have personally a bulb that we use in the clinic
that's probably 10 years old.
And it has never burned out.
Of course, that's really done a true rife.
So it's much lower frequencies.
Other, I tell you, Robert,
you're going to have more chance of bulbs burning out
because you're running higher frequencies
than that's what you really want.
So it's the price you pay for getting better.
Next question.
What would be a good reason to choose
to run Cyrex antibody testing?
So it would be a good reason for,
I'm assuming you're saying a cancer patient
but let's just use for anybody.
So because it's going to apply to a person with cancer as well.
So you'd run antibody testing
if you are suspected that you have either,
so if you're ready auto antibody,
so auto means self.
So if you're ready self antibodies,
you're ready antibodies to your own tissue
to see if you have an autoimmune disease.
So the reason why you'd run that test
is if you have signs or symptoms
that are suggestive of an autoimmune disease.
So what would those be?
Well, they can be as varied as the variable
different autoimmune diseases.
So let's use an example.
I have some early dementia
and I'm forgetting things.
Or I'm having motor or neuron issues
meaning like I'm dropping things
or I'm starting to get a tremor or something like that.
And you're suspected auto antibodies or self antibodies
to neural tissue, to brain tissue.
That would be a perfect valid reason
to run antibody testing.
Let's say I have thyroid issues.
I'm tired all the time.
But my CBC and looks good.
I don't have anemia and I'm having loss of hair
and I'm losing the lateral third of my eye brows
and I read that that is possible thyroid issues.
But the thyroid test that my doctor did
wasn't sufficient to see antibodies.
That would be a reason to run antibody testing.
If you have weird rashes,
any weird symptoms that maybe even watching some videos
on my autoimmune course and you're starting to realize,
boy, this could be me.
That would be a reason to run antibody testing.
Cyrex also runs food antibody testing.
So that's not self antibodies.
So understand the difference.
So self antibodies is antibodies to your own tissue.
You have antibodies to your brain tissue.
You have antibodies to your thyroid gland.
You have antibodies to your pancreas.
You have an autoimmune disease.
Meaning you have antibodies to self tissue.
But also if you have it gut issues,
you have digestive problems.
You know, I have a lot of inflammation.
I can't pinpoint what that is.
It could be diet related.
So if you have antibodies to foods that you're eating or you should say,
if you're eating foods to that which you have antibodies against,
every time you eat those foods,
you're causing this inflammatory reaction.
And you're gutted and you're brain.
And that's not good.
So that would be an indication to run food antibody tests.
Cyrex also has pathogen related antibodies.
So if you think that you had a past pathogen or a present pathogen,
you could run that.
When they have multiple other profiles
that you could run depending on the symptoms that you have.
So if you want to get to the bottom of inflammation and gut problems
and maybe other inflammatory disorders,
you could run food antibody testing,
pathogen antibody testing.
If you want to discover whether you're not,
you have an autoimmune disease.
You have antibodies to your own tissue.
Then you could run self antibodies.
Typically, I run the Cyrex array five of the Cyrex array seven X
to find out that.
So those would be signs and symptoms
would give you indication to run those.
Next question.
How do food allergies play into my cancer diet?
Well, we've had similar questions like this before.
Like, are when you're testing the cheek swab,
are you testing for food allergies?
The answer is no.
We're not testing for food allergies.
And no, when we put you on a cancer diet,
it has nothing to do with food allergies whatsoever.
It has to do with what's driving your cancer.
So, oh, this would be a good question.
Okay, you told me to stay off of dairy by cheek swab test.
But I had been gluten free for years.
Can I start eating gluten now?
No, you can't.
So if you went off gluten at some point in the past,
it was maybe because you had a food sensitivity test
or maybe because you had recommendations based on signs
or symptoms that you had at that given time.
So just because gluten is not driving me my cancer,
it doesn't mean I don't have food sensitivity to gluten.
So, how do food allergies play into my cancer diet?
They're in addition to your cancer diet.
So let's say you're off dairy,
because let's pretend you're off of dairy.
Let's just keep it at that.
That's a driver for your cancer.
So you're on a low, you're on a no dairy diet.
That doesn't mean that you shouldn't test for food allergies
to see if you have any other source of inflammation
that can be causing issues.
So this would be a good reason for a cancer patient
to run a Cyrex array three, array four,
or an array 10, to test for,
do you have antibodies to different foods?
And if you're eating those foods
that when you have antibodies against,
you're going to cause inflammation
and it's going to, is that going to feed your cancer?
No, but it could indirectly hinder your healing
because you're causing inflammation elsewhere.
So your body's trying to kill cancer in your breast
and every time you eat gluten,
might not be driving your cancer,
but you're causing this inflammatory process
at the gut and at the brain.
The inflammation of the gut equals inflammation of the brain.
So you're causing this inflammatory cascade,
and it's taking away from the immune response
that you want to be able to kill cancer cells in your breast.
So that's why I've always said it can be valuable
to run food antibody testing,
even though that isn't related to what's feeding your cancer,
per se, it can indirectly be hindering your ability to heal.
Next question.
If I had a lot of toxins on my testing,
does that correlate to my genetic testing?
Sometimes it does.
I don't know who has this question,
so we could look and see if it did.
And how would it correlate?
So that's a question.
How would my body harm or eat a lot of toxins
correlate to genetic testing?
So remember,
if you ran a toxicity test and you had a lot of toxins,
what does that tell you?
It tells you either A,
you were exposed to an enormous amount of toxins,
and let's pretend you had it perfectly healthy liver,
and you had no genetic defects in your detoxification pathways,
and you had no other damage to liver cells,
you had great glutathione production and SOD
and other oxidative pathways,
and antioxidative pathways were perfectly functioning,
but it was solely because of the rate of toxicity,
the level of toxicity that you were exposed to at any given time,
that overwhelmed your liver's ability to get rid of it
at that given time, so it was shunted into your tissues
and stored it yourselves and your extremely toxic,
because of that one incidence or ten incidence
or daily incidence of exposure,
so you're working in it.
Okay, here's a perfect example.
I had a gentleman, this was years ago,
he had aluminum toxicity.
Have you ever tested on him?
His aluminum was off the chart.
It's like, okay, what's going on?
He was having all these brain fog issues,
and dementia issues, and he was much too early in his life.
He was in his early 50s.
Well, turns out he actually,
what he did is he worked for Delta Airlines,
and he drilled whole,
and he says, all I do is drill holes in aluminum all day long.
That's what I do.
He was a mechanic and did repairs on plates,
and then they were aluminum,
and he was drilling holes,
and of course, you're drilling holes,
you're gasifying some of the solid,
and he was breathing it in.
So he was basically poisoning himself,
and he was, so this was going to be in a worker's cub,
click case, and he ended up going to Mayo,
and getting EDTA,
inner Venus to help pull this out of his body,
and he had changed jobs.
So it was because of his daily exposure to toxic,
it had really maybe little to do with this liver
or a health, maybe, that's always a part.
Nobody has this perfect liver,
nobody has a perfect genetics,
but it had much less to do with that,
and much more to do with his level
and rate of toxic exposure.
So that is the way we get toxic,
but another way we get toxic is we might have just,
we might be exposed to maybe a lower level of toxins,
but we have issues with our liver,
maybe partly genetic,
and partly environmental,
because we've damaged our liver in other ways.
So we're considered,
we'll be considered a slow detox,
or so you just don't get rid of things
that your partner does,
maybe your friend does,
and you are exposed to the same level of toxins,
and you just,
your liver just can handle less.
So it gets stays in your system,
and gets shut into your tissues,
and into the cells,
and can cause cancer and all sorts of problems.
So yes,
the lots of toxins that you might have
can directly correlate
to genetic issues
with detoxification pathways,
we'll be looking at cytochrome P4.
50 pathways,
P1 pathways,
and AT pathways,
glutathione pathways,
SOD pathways,
kind of things that are part of your whole detoxification system.
Next question.
I'm thinking of taking picnoginol
to help the circulation in my legs,
where I have a lot of pain for martinella.
Supposedly, this helps increase nitric oxide.
Last week or so,
I thought you mentioned that those with cancer
should not take nitric oxide.
Would it be okay to take
picnoginol,
since it would be a natural
production of nitric oxide from the picnoginol?
I would say that
for cancer patients to take picnoginol
would be just fine.
I understand that, you know,
the makers and the sellers of a product
like picnoginol
might take a study
and run with maybe one piece of a study
and say,
oh, it's so great for helping
nitric oxide production.
You can look on picnoginol.
It probably says that it's an anti-oxidant
because of that.
And it's an anti-inflammatory.
So then should I not take it
because it's an anti-oxidant?
Picnoginol would be a very miter,
anti-oxid would be a very miter player
in increasing nitric oxide.
It's much more of a TH2 stimulator
than it is anything.
So it could decrease
chronic inflammation.
So I'd say picnoginol
is just fine.
We use to use picnoginol
with Lyme patients.
And the biggest reason
why I liked picnoginol with Lyme
so most people with Lyme
had a retreated word
and autoimmune phase of Lyme.
And taking TH2 stimulators.
So you have two sides of your immune system,
your TH1 side and your TH2 side.
Taking TH2 stimulators
help decrease inflammation.
Your TH1 side is primarily pro-inflammatory.
Your TH2 side is primary anti-inflammatory.
And picnoginol is a anti-inflammatory TH2 stimulator
from PineBark Extract.
So I think you're just fine taking picnoginol.
Next question.
I've heard you say that we should not
take glutathione supplements
if we have cancer.
But is it okay to take NAC
to help boost our glutathione levels naturally
or is it defeating the purpose?
If a person is in full remission of their cancer,
I don't think they have any trouble taking NAC.
So NAC is what NAC is.
And NAC is the precursors to glutathione.
So normally in the mitochondria,
glutathione is recycled.
That's how it works.
That's how important glutathione is
as the main anti-oxidant of a cell.
So in the cell you have mitochondria
and they're making glutathione and recycling glutathione.
And they need cystine and glycine
as components to help with that recycling process
and magnesium and some other cofactors.
So NAC is typically given to help boost glutathione levels.
Now if a person has is in full-blown cancer,
then I'd say no, you shouldn't be adding
too much anesthetal cystine to the system,
unless it tests fine for that person,
but it typically would not.
And you certainly wouldn't take like a glutathione
or the liposomal glutathione supplement
with you have cancer.
But if you're in remission,
you know, helping with glutathione precursors,
which NAC is,
could help you're not dealing with active cancer
that I'd say it's okay to take,
but if you're dealing with active cancer,
I'd say maybe hold off on that.
Are you familiar with EBOO treatments
and do you think it is something
that I could do to help with Lyme and cancer?
So EBOO is extra corp helioblund oxygenation
and ozonation.
It is a therapy that is used.
You sit down and you connect a vein in your arm
and they basically are ozonating oxygenate your blood
for a period of time.
It came out about just 10, 15 years ago
as this very promising therapy.
And there are some cancer clinics
that use the machinery still.
It hasn't really proven to be helpful
to my other study for cancer.
I think where it does shine is with Lyme.
Does it hit their cancer?
Could it be bad for some of these cancer?
No, I don't think so.
Can it be good for cancer?
No, possibly.
It just hasn't shown that promise.
So primarily it's not used so much for cancer
for cancer anymore.
But with Lyme disease or other infections
that are stubborn infections, it can be helpful.
So yeah, no, I think that's just fine.
If you want to do it, I don't see any downsides.
Okay, a question from the chat.
I have been using the Rebuilder for Doropathy regularly
and I think I'm doing it right now.
I do feel tingles when using it.
But sometimes I also feel a Z,
or I know I have a tumor.
Is it possible the Rebuilder could encourage growth in a tumor?
No, no.
It's not possible because it is firing
at the frequency of the nerves, the neurons.
So what you don't want to have growth in a tumor
is you don't want to have vascular growth into a tumor
which would be stimulating vascular endothelial growth factory
and a question about that a few weeks ago.
That's why you wouldn't take nitric oxide.
So you don't take nitric oxide if you have cancer
because you'll be stimulating vascular endothelial growth factory
and you'll be stimulating vessel growth into a solid tumor
which is going to cause the tumor to grow.
The Rebuilder is not going to do that.
So you don't have to worry about that.
Yeah, there's no negatives about that with cancer.
So I think you're safe.
Next question.
When I try to start my programs on my right machine recently
I get a screen that says I'm not connected.
When I X out of that screen, it gives me the screen
that I need to select by desired program.
Question.
Why is this change suddenly?
Maybe I'm rushing the selection process?
Don't want to harm the machine.
So you have the true right machine, I believe.
So these are some of the issues that we've had
with true right updating things.
So you'd want to know what version you're running.
Whether it's version six or version six point four
to be exact.
And then what we really have to walk you through that.
So you'll probably have to call the clinic and schedule a time
to talk to Dustin.
And he could, you know, what he's what you're on the phone with him.
Make sure you're at the right computer.
It's plugged in and everything.
And you could kind of walk through the screen selection
that you would see and he could help you with it.
Is it getting to the point?
My question to me is he getting to the point where it's actually
running the program?
If it is, it may be some update that they did that's about
that's popping up.
You know, that's.
That's that's my complaint with the new owners with true right.
They are owners that are, you know, concerned about making money
in business, not concerned about caring for patients.
Like Mike used to be where he was more centered around doing
everything what's going to help his client base.
Even though he didn't he wasn't a doctor.
He wanted the best care for his clients where the new
owners are kind of taking shortcuts.
So I don't know if that if you updated your programs
lightly or something like that.
So the best thing to do would be to stick call and schedule a time
with Dustin, probably early next week.
Okay, next question from the chat.
By 80 year old son has consulted with you regarding the acne
and is on a gluten and dairy free diet.
He wondered if our homemade broth stock was a good thing to use
for his bone strength, et cetera.
What would you suggest for an addition to his diet sense?
He does not consume any dairy.
Okay, so remember, are you, is dairy causing, is dairy your number
with source of calcium in minerals for your bones?
No, no, so a lot of people in our dairy free diet are like,
oh, what's going to happen if I bone strike this stock to be good?
I'm not eating dairy.
Thinking that that's where I'm getting my minerals from.
So minerals that are in dairy, your body can't use,
but not real effectively.
So I'm not knocking dairy.
First of all, if you're, I know this person who's asking this question
I'm pretty sure isn't, but let's say you're talking about pasteurized dairy.
There's much less value in pasteurized dairy than in raw dairy.
Let's say we're using raw dairy, raw cheese, raw milk,
we're getting from a farmer or from our old cow.
Then there's more value in that.
Whether you pasteurize it, you lose a lot of the value
because you're losing all the enzymes that are helping you absorb
the minerals that are in dairy.
So let me take a step back.
Where do we get most of our minerals from that bill bone,
that bill that we use for coenzymes and cofactors in enzymatic activity
and metabolic activity in our cells?
Most of that is from our vegetables,
summons from grass-fed beef, too, grass-fed meat,
and raw dairy, but most is from your vegetables.
Of course, that takes, okay, I'm not drinking milk.
Where am I going to get my calcium from my bones?
First of all, your bones need a lot more than just calcium,
they need minerals.
Second of all, the biggest source of minerals for your bones
and for your rest of your body is your vegetables.
Third, you get them also from eating grass-fed meats, as well.
So bone broth is at a good form of minerals.
Well, it turns out what you have in it.
If it's just, again, remember, a cancer patient
wouldn't be drinking bone broth.
It's got too much glutamate in it.
I can feed cancer, but non-cancer patient.
You're making bone broth, or you're making soups
with making it correctly.
Oh, is that correctly?
Where you take a chicken, put it in the pot, and your boiling.
Meat falls off, and then you take the chicken out.
Take all the meat off, cut it up, and then you put all your vegetables
in there and you make your soup.
But so you're getting some of the bone nutrients
out of the bones of the animal as well.
So you can do that making bone broth as well.
You're cooking bones on beef bones, or chicken bones,
or whatever bones you're cooking, or cooking them
for a long period of time to get the nutrients out of the bone.
Well, the negative about cancer is you're getting a lot of glutamate
in it, which can feed cancer.
So cancer patients wouldn't want to necessarily do that,
but it can be really good for healing skin,
and healing your gut, and for patients who are autoimmune.
It's part of what's called the GAPS diet,
is using bone broth and brothy soups and things
like that to help heal the gut and to help heal the skin.
So, yes, bone broth and bone stock is excellent
for anybody with autoimmune issues,
anybody with gut issues, anybody with skin issues.
And you get minerals from it too, yes,
but it's really the other healing products of it
that I even exceed that.
So, yes, he can get his nutrient, a lot of nutrients
from broth and soups and things like that.
Any other questions?
Okay, well, thanks everybody for being on today,
and we'll talk to everybody next week,
have a blessed week, and bye-bye.